[Applause]
kanye
is quote unquote running for president
he just did his uh his big uh
campaign launch i guess you could say
press conference
that was a press conference something
like that or there's a there's a term
for these events campaign rally
rally yeah rally yeah
so um what do we think in here
i mean for me it seems that this is the
same kanye cycle i don't know why people
haven't caught up on this already but
it's like
cause some sort of like commotion
drop music cause commotion drop music
cause commotion yeah drop music right
like what are other times where he did
it uh
just about every i'm trying to think of
the other famous ones that we can think
of though
life of pablo tmz situation the tmz
situation
then he drops the album um was that the
same time when he was wearing the maga
hat
yeah i think those are the same too yeah
um
i wonder if the uh george bush don't
care about black people was that
followed by an album at all
no that was just really in the moment
[ __ ]
i think he had already i think he had
already dropped college dropout i think
yeah college does a four that he said
that until the five
yeah right well look point is it seems
like this is the pathway
for kanye right and uh but it seems to
be
continuing to work and he was at this he
has had this rally and he said some very
interesting things you guys already
probably saw by now but uh
he said the thing about how he's like
super against abortion
yeah he said he'll pay you a million
dollars to not have an abortion right
bet yeah that's pretty easy bad yeah
like let's go i think if people had a
million dollars they wouldn't have an
a loan but you know what i mean like
that's why they're getting abortions
because they don't have the money like
it's easy to be a guy who's a
billionaire going i'm not gonna abort
any of my kids it's like yeah
it's like the [ __ ] when ugly dudes go
i'm not gonna cheat on my girl
yeah you're not yeah you are not yeah
there's no way
and if i'm not mistaken he said it will
be paid for by
africa and israel africa and israel are
going to pay for what
for people to not get abortions the
million dollars
i mean this is just unbelievable here's
why i think he's actually
gone off the rails for real that clip of
him crying
saying like i almost killed my daughter
when he's talking about abortions
i was like oh this guy's actually gone
now yeah he's actually gone and nobody
in that [ __ ] none of your in-laws are
gonna save you this is just like they
know next season the ratings are going
to be through the [ __ ] roof and
they're happy to let it happen
yeah you're probably right that's where
i was like when he said the harry tubman
[ __ ] i thought it was hilarious
she didn't he just got them employed by
other white people just so funny so yeah
say the whole thing he said something
like harry he's starting to start my
hairy tummy he's like well harry when
she freed the slaves he goes well
harry tubman didn't really free the
slaves she just had them working for
other white people
which is like yeah the ones who weren't
slave owners
she was working not slaving yeah the big
difference between those you get to go
home at the end of the night
one has a paycheck yeah yeah i mean
anyway how could he be
that like just dense he's like no he's
not dumb i really think he's
that i was like oh this could be pr
whatever when i saw him crying like i
was like either he's a fantastic actor
yeah
or he's actually gone and it is we act
like he's different than the homeless
guy on the subway who's ranting for
non-stop for 45 minutes the entire train
ride because he's a billionaire yeah
he's that mentally gone he's that
mentally troubled do you think it's
possible he just has access to so many
like
wild people and like interesting people
that are able to put things in his ear
and yeah he just like grabs on to people
whose like
stuff sounds interesting to him bro you
know who he spoke to before he went on
tmz who put all that [ __ ] in his ear
eric weinstein
really yeah who's weinstein he's one of
these like uh
intellectuals that'll be on like the
rogan podcast a lot
um but yeah so he spoke and so eric
weinstein is like telling him
all these things that maybe if
articulated via eric weinstein would be
far more
digestible right but he just picks up on
what was it slavery was a choice slavery
was a choice
like what yeah but it's possible you
could go on like a logical
train to be like technically maybe blah
blah is it also impossible that a crazy
person hears those or a person who's
mentally unwell hears that and then
hears
hey don't get an abortion i'll give you
a million dollars china and israel will
pay for it or africa
israel will pay for it like could it be
a mentally crazy person here's a smart
person talking
and then it goes through their brain and
they're like oh yeah africa will pay for
you to not have a baby
100 i mean like he's just in a position
where he has the most interesting
brilliant people ever reaching out to
him that he could talk to he got access
to them
right man like who knows i'm not putting
this on candace owns but like
it's not the craziest thing to hear a
conservative person say that harriet
tubman just got
black people working for different white
people
it could be a woke sentence in a
different context if it's like yo
slavery never ended
right that's the thing it's like how you
encase
ideas is so important yeah like if
for example if that sentence came from
one of like these like super woke
activist types yeah and they were like
yeah we were free in the north but we
were still oppressed we were still
treated like [ __ ] we were second class
citizens
we couldn't get jobs we did all this
other stuff it's like so y'all created
new slavery here
yeah if that was the context of in which
it was said
i don't think anybody gives near the
amount of pushback but the way that he
has a
i mean like the way he kind of like the
idea of
13th the documentary is they just found
a new way to enforce slavery with the
prison
industrial complex right that's
something we all look at and it's like
oh [ __ ] that makes a lot of sense
coming from a guy who just spouts it out
slavery never ended
harry tubman and franny slaves it's just
like i need to say slavery never
just like what do we do with that that's
just a crazy person talking
yo but you guys said something about
kanye that um and it's a characteristic
of people
that are losing it a little bit they get
people away from them that
oh yeah so can you make that argument
about trump
because he has a lot of those
characteristics i don't see
trump as someone who's mentally ill i i
don't see it
i only has people around him that is
feeding him the knowledge that he wants
to hear even if the knowledge is wrong i
don't think that's an exclusive quality
to crazy people
i would also say about trump from from
everybody that i've met that has met
trump
what everybody said to me it was the
same exact thing
really nice but then they go this they
go
curious i go what do you mean they go he
just asks questions
what do you do and then explain to me
what you do
and why you're good at it oh and why is
this like that why is this like
and it was an interesting and i think
important characteristic now
does he want to be around does he want
to have like sycophants around him is
that the knock on him sure
or does he want to have people that will
execute
what he thinks is the right thing to do
and
he feels like in dc if he doesn't have
someone who's on his side he has someone
who's actively trying
to take him down that would be what i'm
thinking like
if i'm going to dc right i'm bringing
y'all
not because i think y'all agree with me
because i think that y'all are going to
give me the best perspective
maybe at the end of the day we have like
the common goal together
all right but akash might be like nah
you're going too crazy you got to pull
back on that
you know what i mean okay fine i agree
with you i'll pull back on that we all
want this to happen how we get to there
might have different methodology and
that's where you lean on people so maybe
he got people who agree
with where he wants the country to go
but they might disagree on the best way
to get there
does that make sense i get it but i
don't see that
it might be i might be completely wrong
and it could be wrong where he wants the
country to go you should not be able to
scratch your entire achilles tendon yo
so i put on some lotion so my i got
eaten up by bugs bro
i got literally destroyed by bugs you
don't see all these bug bites
bro on my [ __ ] ankle bro i think they
came in when you were the [ __ ]
honeycombs on your feet
literally you walked in look at all
these bug bites all over me because you
had two honeycombs on your feet
what's you doing yo bro i'm i'm going
through a dog i might have
what do dogs have again please fleas bro
you got fleas
i might have fleas i really might have
it
all right scratch himself what else we
got what else we got
okay what is the abortion thing with
kanye i know we touched on it but did we
really said he'd pay you a million
dollars and not get an abortion right
and then he said he almost aborted his
daughter
yeah so he he broke down crying because
he was like oh
that's why he's against abortion because
he's like if i would have had my way i
wouldn't have my daughter right now
and if his dad who didn't want him had
his way he wouldn't be alive
oh his dad didn't want him no really
that's what he
says but and not to mention there's a
movement
within like black conservatism
specifically that's like harping on
abortion
as like a bit like one of their like uh
talking points yes
and in what way because they're like so
basically they put abortion clinics like
abortion lawyers pop up in poor
neighborhoods
right and poor neighborhoods are
predominantly black in like urban cities
and stuff
right or uh maybe poor neighbors aren't
predominantly black
but they're going to be a higher
percentage of black poor neighborhoods
that's a better way to put it right
right right and so as a result a lot of
black people in america have abortions
and they have them at higher rates than
like their representation of the
population or something yes
i read it was something like 50 of
abortions something like that so now
black conservatives who are obviously
against abortion are like yo they're
killing our people blah blah
and so that's what right so that's
popped up in black conservative areas
and i think
he's got black conservatives in his ear
that are like yo you gotta push us out
there
[Applause]